Joey betta get in here now
what's up guys I really like spider-man
what do you think that's why you called
us in here uh-huh yeah in that case yeah
dude that's good
[Music]
Cuoco
I've gotta say I am a an old-school
Spidey guy all the way back from the
comics so you know to me the best thing
about this game is how they nail
spider-man's dynamics and movements
during the city like even now and I've
played about maybe 20 hours of this game
I still find really cool things that I'm
seeing him do when he's actually out
there swinging through the city and it
makes it makes me makes my heart fill
with joy
yeah I don't even like spider-man as a
character or like a franchise but that
is the best stuff in this game that just
happened yeah I'm getting reports of a
helicopter with a wrecking ball yeah
things that the demons
you know all that said right like even
though that this is a part of every
single thing the game is doing I still
find pieces of the game that made me
kind of scratch my head and think wow
this is this is an old-school superhero
game for better and for worse it is it
has a lot of sort of modern touches but
yeah when you do get in there and you do
get around the city you know once you do
sort of get over that joy of being
spider-man and being kinetic and you
know like going through the air the
structure of it is fairly old school
right it's the whole yeah you go up to a
point which becomes a tower you activate
it and then suddenly all these
activities sort of spring up around your
map did that guys sort of like break you
out of it at all I enjoyed it I know you
exploited it I mean you've basically run
through who did it you use me well
you've like run through everything in
the game pretty much right yeah it out
for you I have a hundred percent right
now yeah yeah but for me like I don't
know I kind of enjoyed that sort of
old-school like almost ps2 ps3 era style
of open-world right we're like you have
the entire city of Manhattan it's huge
but there aren't many times that you go
actually use the city it's more like you
go to a point in they go to a loading
screen and then it's like this certain
section that you can use yeah like it's
like the way its story is set up and
segmented is very rigid and linear like
when you get to a thing it's like it
knows to take you out of your suit right
away like you don't really see a lot of
that transitionary stuff as you go from
the open world to the more scripted
stuff yeah and some of the more scripted
stuff so every time you're out of the
suit was actually the poorest bits of
the game for me not surprisingly you
sometimes out there as Peter Parker you
sometimes that there is several other
characters as well and you know Mary
Jane in particular has a few sequences
where it's more stealth focused and I
enjoyed those initially but then it sort
of started to get a little bit grating
you know on me by the end to the point
that you know I just couldn't wait to
get back into the spider-man suit
because being in that suit was just so
exhilarating that he you know I think it
plastered over some of the more
old-school elements for me yeah I do
like the way Mary Jane is sort of
portrayed now I don't have a whole lot
of context for like if she's ever been
like this sort of character before but I
think her her confidence you know the
fact that
and Peter Parker have a history together
it's not like he's like pining for her
right like you're trying to get to that
point that feels cool because I've seen
that so many times in movies at least
but then to just yeah kind of like
detract for her character by forcing in
these gameplay sections I just don't
feel like they belong
they're certainly not necessary and the
second thing I'm going to do is collect
your head Craig dang she's pissed it is
most definitely a threat uh-huh what did
you guys think of the actual open world
nature of this because you know New York
I think it looks beautiful in this thing
and as I said swinging through it is
amazing but once you actually get on the
ground like you know a lot of that
facade sort of just washes away I think
a little bit I think it does a very good
job at making the city feel busy mm-hmm
but knowing that there's not a whole lot
to actually do when you're on foot is
maybe a little bit like maybe a little
disappointing I think yeah like you
don't want to spend too much time on
foot anyway and the game makes it very
easy to just get back to swinging if you
do happen to fall to the ground but yeah
if you take the moment to really look at
the NPC's and and interact with the
things that in the environment I mean
you can grab a mailbox and suite around
your head and throw it at a stranger
right in front of police you can throw
this up at police and it doesn't usually
like the game is pretty good about when
you throw something it'll make it go to
the left or to the right but there's
some times when you are definitely just
like I should be breaking that car I
should be hurting that person I should
be arrested you should be killing a lot
of people doing the spider-man things
you do but I guess you know in this game
the city really is purely for traversal
you know like that's what it's there for
you know I did try when I first got the
game just walking around you know
occasionally giving high-fives to people
that esteem yeah it does run out of
steam so you know once you actually get
past that yeah you're right there isn't
really much to June occasionally some
dynamic elements which you know like a
crime will yeah well I can't car
accident we get to like lift cars off of
people and stuff like that like works
really well but that's that happens as
you're swinging around and then you're
pulled down to it you don't really find
that stuff organically if you're just
there
hey wouldn't be New York without a sudra
you guys are like little kingpins in
training
so you've wanted to send in this game
how long did it actually take you to do
that I don't know I want to say between
somewhere like 35 40 hours yeah not sure
though but that includes doing
everything including all the crimes
which that was the one thing that kind
of slowed me down near the end were
after I finished all the missions all
these like side quests I'm left with a
whole lot of crimes to define basically
because they don't there aren't
locations that you have to swing and
then you'll get the call say like oh
it's happening on like fifth and you
know Broadway or whatever and then you
go to it and it's important to do those
because that it's tied into progression
right like there's certain things that
you need those crime tokens and other
tokens to unlock suits and you know
other abilities and yeah those those
things are also like really good and you
do get this like sense of constant
progression and improvement but it's did
you find I wanted to ask you like do you
find that it kind of had diminishing
returns over time as the game went on in
terms of like the new stuff you were
getting because I'm getting close to
that point now where it's I feel like I
have all the big new stuff even though I
still see that there are things to
unlock I'm not really excited about it
yeah it's mostly like once you get like
the main like gadgets most of your
currency is gonna go towards like
upgrades to those so it's not entirely
necessary but if you want to hundred
percent like I did yeah then you're
gonna spend a lot of time just kind of
wandering around just hoping that you'll
see a red icon somewhere no are you
saying more people that you know you've
got given the abilities that you wanted
to use rather early and you do feel like
experimenting with the other stuff that
they all gave you I felt there was a lot
of growth early on right so it was
tangible additions to my skill set that
I could then put into use and see those
you know make me change the way that I
not only moved around the world but
handle myself in combat right and I
actually find combat to be fairly easy
in this game it uses that familiar for
lack of a better you know comparison the
Arkham Knight games right it you know if
you pay attention to Spider Man and you
sort of keep an eye on what's around him
you know when to dodge you know how to
protect yourself you can get overwhelmed
but having these abilities made it
easier to you know manipulate combat
and sort of you know crowd control and I
didn't actually mind at the combat that
some say just could be a bit easy and a
little bit simplistic if you you know if
you just want to ball back boil it down
to its base mechanics it's you know
punch dodge Travis but I didn't mind
that because you know as I got better in
the game it made really fit into that
whole power fantasy I have I ran
spider-man in which when his has he's at
its best he's untouchable you know like
all these guys are trying to shoot at
him you know throw punches at him and
he's just sort of zipping around going
into people's legs and just being this
like you know incredible Acrobat and it
made me feel really good so for me like
combat never really sort of dull you
know in the time that I played this game
yeah yeah it becomes a canvas for
creativity with your skills I just I
don't know if I still have that
excitement that I that I earned at one
point
[Music]
there's a moment we thought may that
kind of struck me as odd where Peter
Parker is this like wholesome well-to-do
guy and his you know Aunt May is there
and he's like look I really want to help
out around the the shelter and she's
like oh you don't have to I mean I know
I don't have to I want to I want to
she's like so touched meanwhile he's
only saying that so he can like ransack
someone's office and steal info he's
just lying to his on it's like the
character of Peter Parker to me isn't
really hitting any high notes Oh III
gotta say though like I know I've read a
lot about spider-man and his you know
like the kinetics of him in this game
but I actually think they really nailed
the Peter Parker character in this I'm
quite well because you know like the
stage at which the story is that is you
know it's a few years into his
spider-man career now so he's you know
he's working he's you know he's out of
high school it's just been about a
decade I think you know since he
actually put on the suit and he's still
struggling and and that is like
quintessential Peter Parker from the
comic books you know he's the guy who
could you know very brilliant super
brave a spider-man but could never
actually get it together in his actual
life you know always falling behind
bills you know like always you know
jeopardizing his relationships because
he couldn't actually balance both sides
of his life properly and I think this
game sort of really nails that so you
know you know a lot of spider-man games
can you know get the the kinetic of
spider-man right but there's one of the
few ones that I think you know has got
both sides of the personality oh you are
so much like Ben you have to learn to
swallow that Parker pride and accept
that you're human like the rest of us
and also really like the spider-man is a
scientist in this one like you know all
the puzzles that you do the puzzles are
good yeah surprisingly surprisingly why
is that surprising because I didn't know
the repose in this game I didn't expect
that and then they feel different enough
and easy to understand that I it feels
like a nice kind of break from the
action that I've been doing like
throughout
[Music]
as I said you know I know I'm in love
with this game because you know I love
the fact that they've nailed the
spider-man and it's what I've always
seen in my head you know how we actually
moves and you know it's great we're
living in this sort of Renaissance of
comic book geek curry right now you know
I think the movies have obviously sort
of nailed that whole Marvel aesthetic
and we not think we've been waiting for
that sort of like first big game to come
along and also you know really nail the
the Marvel thing and you know I think
we've actually got in there yeah but it
is still an old-school game at heart
it's still a very old-school game at
heart but you know if you're a big
Spidey fan like me that's great
come on Peter move you I'm gonna you got
me like here like play like here what is
that are we doing clock not quite all
the way there we go
no Tina come on do it
make the Sam if you need to sound the
sideway sound no that's not actually it
is clip
[Music]